Thank you very much.
I should say that after our next speaker
we're delighted to have Yale's political science
eminence,
Professor Doug Ray, author of "City", a remarkable
book that deals with the
origins of some of these problems
in our very own city
who will
moderate the questions afterwards. But first
Tom Vanderbilt.
Okay, great, can everyone hear me okay?
Great to see such a
big turnout here.
I was just at a conference in Austin for the Texas
Department of Transportation.
One of the commissioners there was decrying
what he thought the view of transportation
as a central importance to our lives.
The view of transportation
to the average person
as he put it in I thought a very Texas way, was about
as sexy as putting socks on a rooster.
So to use Don's analogy of dogs and cats,
I tend to think I was sort of a pidgin,
kind of flitting about the streets, picking up
what I could hear and there from all sorts of
different aspects
of traffic, and this is
the book I've written. Don is one of the many people
in it, whose work I was really trying to
bring to this wider public. And I'm a
journalist by training, no background
in transportation planning or
anything like that. Just the presence of
this here is making me very
nervous.
These are the sorts of things I would typically skip in
a lot of transportation papers and get to the
conclusion to find out
the truth.
So anyways, this is the book I've written. It's
been published in a number of different countries,
which is
interesting.
And this is a fascinating process,
not without a few moments lost in translation.
If you notice in the German edition down here in the
lower left hand corner,
they went with the title "Auto" instead of "Traffic",
and I
called up the publisher. I said this is a little different,
I'm curious about this. It's not really a book about the car,
it's more about traffic, and they said, well,
Tom, in German the word "traffic" is actually
synonymous with the word for intercourse.
And I spent a few minutes on the phone trying to explain
why this actually wouldn't be a bad thing to
confuse the mind of
a consumer,
but
he didn't buy that.
I just wanted to begin...
So I live in Brooklyn. I have a particularly unique
relationship to parking. I do own a car, which is a very
strange thing, and we have a very
interesting form of what's called transportation
demand management in New York City, which
is that you
basically don't leave your space, you don't
ever drive because of fear
not only losing a great space you have, but
of encountering
sort of angry natives when you return and
do something wrong.
But even within New York-- a minority
of New Yorkers actually own cars--
but even within New York there's interesting
variations between neighborhoods. I know
there's a Jackson Heights
resident--former Jackson Heights resident-- here somewhere,
and an interesting study looked at two neighborhoods
in Brooklyn, which is where I live, and
you know if you're transportation planner
sort of looking at this, you might
go up and down the line here and think that well
Park Slope here is a wealthier
part of town. There's a few more cars there.
Certainly they must sending more vehicles
the central business district.
In fact it was actually Jackson Heights, and something
like forty percent more people were actually driving
into the central business district, and
the reason was that
Jackson Heights people tend to have
little parking spaces protected. They have curb
cuts, they have garages,
so this is something that
the mere presence of this protected parking
spot emboldened them to drive and
change their behavior in a way that...
…It's sort of Economics 101. Incentives matter.
Whereas I
am kind of afraid to drive anywhere.
This is sort of a 1970 image,
sort of the high point of getting
over the city to the automobile.
I'm a child of the early 1970's, and
it's been interesting to sort of note the
sort of unsustainable path we've been on. We talk about
the American
love affair with the automobile,
and some people joke that it's long ago
turned into a marriage, but
it's interesting for me to track how much
this has changed even in the past two decades since
I've been around.
Another way to look at parking here,
this is Brian Pijanowski, a geographer
at Purdue who
did a sort of heat map here of all the available
parking spaces in Tippecanoe county,
Indiana. These are just the municipal
sort of parking lot. This isn't residential stuff.
He found there are basically three times as many
parking spaces as there are actual residents in the
town,
that
parking lots occupied twenty percent more space than the
businesses they served.
That if you were to extend this relationship to the
country, to America,
Connecticut and Massachusetts would have to be turned into
entirely parking lots,
and that basically that if everyone in this county got
up and drove around at the same time,
there'd be something on the order of 250,000
parking spaces still available, just sort of
sitting there.
So massive sort of overabundance of
parking and I should say road space.
The Rand Corporation has estimated that ninety percent
of American roads are not congested ninety
percent of time.
But, you know, this is another thing that's
changed remarkably. In 1960, this
was almost unheard of, a three-car garage. Now
one in five new homes
has one of these.
And what's interesting is that this sort of
relationship began to change even as American
households were getting smaller, and arguably
houses for the many smaller. But it
sort of speaks to the idea that we hear them talk
about the population
increase contributing to congestion, and in
some cases it does, but
what's really changed over the past few decades
is this
incredible increase in vehicle miles traveled, which is
VMT of course.
From 1968 to 2000,
the population grew about forty percent, the number
the number of vehicle miles travelled
increased 160%, so
I sort of, and most of this I should say
was what's called discretionary driving,
not work-related
commuting,
this driving, so
I tend to blame the rise of organized
youth soccer,
for the sort of
fast increase that was going on here. But
there's some other things kind of rising at a
similar rate
during that period.
And we lay a lot of blame
at the foot of sort of corn syrup and things
like that, but
clearly this
tracks the VMT increase pretty well.
Sheldon Jacobson has pointed out that as
Americans have gotten heavier, this is of course
in a sort of perverse feedback loop,
our fuel economy has declined because it
requires more energy to move
these heavier American around, so it's sort of
a negative feedback loop.
Of course we have ways of counteracting
this obesity thing. We
drive to the gym, and this is an actual...
it's in San Diego…it's an
actual gym. Some people think this photo
was doctored, but I
borrowed this from Dan Burden, this
great image.
Now this is--talk about being a child of the 70's--this is an iconic house, the Brady Bunch house.
And we think about
suburbia, obviously people do more driving,
but even again
in these past few decades as a measure
of how things have changed.
The Brady Bunch house on the walk
score web site interestingly
scores an 82, which is
not the
98 percent that my Brooklyn neighborhood does,
but still
pretty decent compared to
what's come along since then, which is places like Henderson,
Nevada, one of the epicenters of the subprime
crisis, were you're getting walk scores in the neighborhood
of about 50.
Now just another thing that has changed
in that time.
First McDonald's drive thru came out in 1975.
I always thought this happened much
earlier, but
McDonald's now does a majority of their business
through the drive thru, so McDonald's is sort of a nice little
icon of car dependency. McDonald's has
become a car independent country.
So these demographic things are interesting, but wasn't
really what motivated me to write
the book. What really motivated me was
just some sort of
questions I had as a long-time driver, participant in
this environment that I think is so ubiquitous
and yet overlook, and so
I was trying to sort of understand some of the
things about the behavior of other drivers, about
the way traffic worked,
sort of understand this
environment. And so I had
simple questions in mind that I wanted to ask.
I want to show you a clip
from a film that I think demonstrates one of these
traffic phenomena quite well.
We can just go through this, this is Office Space.
The phenomenon I'm talking about
is the sensation you may have in traffic when the other
lane always moves faster. Okay so now this is a really, a real
phenomenon that i think we've all experienced,
and what's interesting though is that some
Canadian researchers actually
identified what was going on here. It's an interesting
cognitive illusion because about
ninety percent of our time spent driving
we're looking forward, which sort of makes
sense.
There's something that happens by which we actually
spend more time watching other vehicles
physically pass us than we see ourselves passing
other vehicles.
This illusion is made worse by the closer
we drive to the car in front of us
and the more glances we make in the neighboring lane.
It increases the sense of this
kind of illusion. So we always sort of feel that we're coming
out on the losing end in a traffic situation.
This I think plays into what Daniel Kahneman has called
loss aversion, by which the human brain actually
registers losses much more powerfully than it does gains.
And this is a case,
if you talk to many traffic engineers, they would say well
in many cases it would be better if no one actually
changed lanes,
what seems best for the individual user, user
optimality, actually makes the system work.
This guy's probalby changing lanes because someone
did what he did
about a mile ahead and there's sort of a
butterfly effect that can happen that is
almost a version of chaos theory.
Now another question
I had was
this idea of congestion, was it always
an instance of there not being enough capacity,
was there always a bottleneck, was it a result of an
accident on-ramp, adding new vehicles to a system.
Some Japanese physicists did a
fascinating experiment. They got a closed track,
and asked a group of drivers to
maintain a steady speed and following distance
and keep this up for as long as they could,
and you'll see that because humans are not robotic
devices that
over time a bit of sort of noise begins
to enter the system, people begin to drive
closer, they fail to react in time, they overreact,
they brake harder than they should...
And out of this sort of perfect closed system,
stop and go congestion begins to emerge
just the sheer actions of drivers, and
there's been some interesting modeling done looking
at people on cellphones because you have a delayed
reaction.
People on cellphones actually
exacerbating the situation, making it worse.
Now there's a solution that's out there, which I rode in
New York about a year ago. This
is a
vehicle called Junior, which is the Stanford
University entry in the DARPA Urban
Challenge.
A fully automated Volkswagen Passat.
I rode for him for a few blocks. Junior can
sort of see everything around with radar
and a variety of censors.
Unlike many New York City drivers, he actually
has full compliance with
various traffic signals, stop signs and
after few blocks you sort of get used to the idea that
you're being piloted around by this
automatic vehicle. Of course, Junior would have
no trouble maintaining this steady speed and following
distance, so this is one
version of the future, which is coming.
Now another idea of the way we contribute
to our own traffic problems, of course the famous one is
rubbernecking.
Some Dutch researchers
sent me this a while ago, and they
did interesting sort of...
…and waited for a crash to happen
on a Dutch highway,
and this was a van rollover on top here,
luckily not fatal, but what you see is
obviously you see there's a
capacity drop in the top section here. People
are having to move over,
do some merging activity,
there's about a twelve percent reduction,
I think they estimated.
But what's interesting--so there's a physical bottleneck--
but if you look at the very wide median strip
across there,
vehicles are actually slowing exactly where the van is,
there's sort of a mental bottleneck
that has emerged.
They also modeled that the drivers were merging
from this queue slower than they would in
normal stop and go congestion.
So clearly that accident was having an effect on them.
They're sort of distracted, perhaps pausing to contemplate
their own mortality.
This is something we all sort of know anecdotally
happens, but it's nice to see
the actual of data out there and have this stuff modeled.
So, the reviewer for the New York Times
suggested that my book should be called simply "Idiots",
and this was one question I was tasked with,
which was why people seemed to
do these
dumb things on the road as a California
highway patrol officer put it to me, why we seem
to act on the road as if we were suffering
from a cranial-rectal inversion.
Part of the problem I think is we
often underestimate the sheer complexity of driving.
It's been estimated for example that every two
miles the average driver makes 400 observations,
40 decisions,
and one mistake.
But the idea, and I was really
trying to get to this idea that Jacques Tati
got to in his film "Traffic", which I would recommend
if haven't seen it,
which is the idea that we become different
people when we enter
an automobile.
Clearly, and for the traffic engineers in the
house tonight,
managing traffic and mobility is sort of a long-standing
problem. This is
an image that comes from the ruins of Pompeii.
You see the chariot ruts still extant in the street.
They've put these sort of walkways across
there
so pedestrians can cross without being
drenched by mud.
And you see it's lined up perfectly
so that the chariots can cross through these crossings.
It's kind of an interesting echo of today's
speed cushions,
traffic calming devices, which have nice cuts so
emergency vehicles can drive over them
faster than normal cars.
Pompeii even had some early bollards,
devices to block vehicles from using
certain streets.
And this idea of managing different modes
of mobility and tension on the road,
road rage, the modern
phrase. Actually it's not modern at all.
This is a painting from the nineteenth century.
Managing these various loads has been a longstanding
problem, and
just when it seemed
as if things could not get more complicated on the
road along came this new
form of personal mobility,
the first real innovation since Caesar's Rome,
which upset this fragile balance.
I'm talking here about the bicycle of course. This
incredibly controversial device in the late nineteenth
century. The New York Times called them
rubber-shod missiles of the highway.
Horse carriages didn't want them in the street,
pedestrians didn't want them on the sidewalk. Where
do you put this thing?
Strange new etiquette questions: should men yield to women?
So this is an ancient sort of problem, and
it brings up something that's been termed a
modal bias, which
when you enter a car, this idea that you become
sort of transformed to another sort of person.
This comes from the Motor Mania, which was a
Walt Disney short from the 1950s.
I think it gets to this wonderfully. It starts, and Goofy,
the dog, begins life as Mr. Walker,
a very sort of
innocent person, wouldn't hurt anyone,
becomes a homicidal maniac the second he enters
an automobile.
So I think humans have trouble often looking outside of ourselves,
and there's something ecologists talk about, which is called
the fundamental attribution error,
in which we we basically attribute the actions
of others to something about their nature or their
character, and when we're asked to explain
our own actions,
we attribute it to situational factors.
You fell; I was pushed. THat's a nice phrase to sort of
summarize this. I think we see this
in driving a lot in part because of stress,
in part because we're often acting on such imperfect
information.
We make
judgments based on the slightest bit of extra
information such as
a person's license plate.
And this is one of the iron laws of driving in America,
the worst drivers are always in the neighboring
state.
And sometimes we get this information quite
wrong in interesting ways. One of my favorite studies
looked at…students looked at two clips
of a car being driven, a BMW and
a sort of smaller VW.
They were asked a week later to estimate the
speed at which each vehicle was traveling at.
A firm majority of subjects said the BMW must
have been driven faster.
In fact they were driven at exactly the same speed.
So we have these sort of mental models of what's happening
out there
that often don't
correlate to reality.
Now one classic probelm with traffic and
driver behavior is anonymity, so
I think I'll just talk a little about
the online disinhibition effect
on which we sort of sign on to an anonymous
chat room, we're protected behind a username that
is not our own.
We're free to
sort of act how we want to act without any repercussion.
I think you can think of traffic this way
with millions of sort of anonymous users interacting
daily,
protected by our license plates.
We do not see the same people
twice in traffic. It's sort of an
obvious thing, but it brings up some interesting
experimental games that have been done in economics,
looking at trying to get people to cooperate when you have
to do things like contribute
money to a common pool,
the cooperation rate seems to soar
when people have the ability to punish people
in later rounds.
In traffic we kind of lack this
accountability, the ability to punish
other people. And of course there are some web sites
that have come up
where you can, sort of, you know, make comments about other
drivers, but not a lot of people sort of look at
these systems, which
makes it tricky.
A somewhat related problem is overconfidence.
Drivers are famously overconfident, and
one place overconfidence flourishes in the lack of
effusive feedback. Now airline pilots
are trained
rigorously in the importance of accepting feedback
from the co-pilots.
Drivers are less receptive to this sort of
feedback from their passengers
to put it politely, but passengers are literally
life-saving devices. Studies have been done.
Solo drivers are involved in crashes at
a higher rate than people with passengers.
One reason passengers are good for us
is they provide something we're often missing in
driving, and that's feedback.
And interesting work
done neurologically looking at the
mind of a driver while they're in a
simulated driving environment versus
a passenger. Entirely different neural networks being
activated. They are in essence different people.
On the notion of feedback, I for the last few months
had a
small device plugged into the on board
diagnostic port in my car,
which measures, which is that kind of thing
mechanics look at when your check engine light goes on, and
it actually has a lot of interesting information that
courses there that's pretty much ignored.
And with an accelerometer and a GPS device, this little
device I have plugged in there tracks my driving,
tells me all sorts of things about it,
gives me a report card at the end of the
month. Things like hard braking,
jack rabbit starts, even
idling, and idling is one of these, you know,
the sort of American idle,
we consume
the amount of energy that Costa Rica
expends in a year just by our idling.
So often people aren't aware of this
behavior, and
feedback is a kind of mechanism to make them aware.
I've sort of
even driving up here today,
the CEO of this company,
whose name is David,
I've started to
call the device David. that's sitting in my
car. I sort of feel like he's watching over me
as I'm driving.
Someone cuts in front of me, I have to brake
harder than I want to,
I sort of think David's going to think I was
driving recklessly, but it was really that person's fault.
So, one problem with feedback, though, is delivering it effectively,
and a guy named Clifford Nass at Stanford has done some
interesting
research for BMW and found out when male drivers were given
warnings
by a female voice in their car that their driving
needed to be improved,
their driving actually deteriorated.
Another problem with traffic is that we
lack traditional signals for human communication,
which
Americans particularly
are constantly trying to say things to one another, but
I think that traffic is sort of a living laboratory of
human interaction. I took this image
in Beijing, a place where
one form of transportation is yielding
to another quite literally,
but it's a place thriving with these sort of subtle displays
of implied power. It's basically a giant applied psychology
laboratory.
And this is a…
you can see this
at work in parking lots appropriately. One
of my favorite studies looked at people
who were
waiting to vacate their parking space.
They found that when this was actually measured,
when another driver was waiting for that driver to leave
the parking space, the person took longer
to leave that space than when no one was
waiting.
Even though on surveys they said they
wouldn't do this. Another great place to
see this behavior at work
is at
intersections,
traffic lights, and psychologists will do an
interesting experiment where they'll
stop a car at a red light,
wait till the light turns green,
and then not move that vehicle.
And then measure who's sort of behind there,
how quickly they honk,
how many times they honk, how long each honk is
because honking, you know, is sort of a subtle
language going on there.
They find that the patterns are decidedly not random.
Men honk more quickly than women,
people in expensive cars
are quicker to the horn than people driving
more modest vehicles.
People in convertibles with the top
down were less likely to honk than others.
When the driver appeared to be
from a different country,
and when the driver had appeared to be on a cellphone,
this generated a faster honk
than in
other conditions.
So there's all sorts of these, you know,
almost subconscious behaviors going on out there as
we move around, and we don't necessarily
think about it, which is one of the things that
fascinates me about the traffic environment,
that is
a guy named Ian Walker who is also in the book, a traffic
psychologist from England did an
interesting set of experiments, rode around on
his bike,
hooked up a censor,
which measured the distance of passing cars
to his bicycle, and he
rode in a variety of different conditions.
He put a helmet on, he did not put a helmet on, and he
wore what
he deemed to be a feminine wig. And he found that
people's passing distances
varied with each conditions, when he had the helmet
on,
drivers passed more closely to him
than when he was not wearing the helmet, and
when he had the feminine wig,
drivers actually gave him more space. This might have been
actually confusion that he was actually Weird
Al Yankovic.
Now, another thing that Ian has talked
a lot about is the
importance of eye contact in the traffic environment,
something that we don't necessarily
think about that much, but
something that is generally missing.
If you look in the image on the left,
I'm not sure if this works way in the back there.
Something probably looks a little bit off about
this image.
What's happening is that Ian's, one of his eyes
is slightly shifted by a few pixels out of a
field of hundreds,
and we're incredibly sensitive to this,
we can sort of pick it out
from across the room. And
psychologists have even done eye-tracking experiments
where they look at where people are looking
when they first look at an image of a car,
and they find that their eyes are drawn
to the headlights which resemble eyes.
And there's a good reason we're so sensitive to this
eye contact
because it's an important tool in gaining social
cooperation.
And a lot of studies have shown this. One of
my favorite
takes place in a university break room.
There was an
honor system for paying for coffee.
Take your coffee, put in
the requested amount.
And above the coffee machine they put on alternating weeks
an image of human eyes
or an image of flowers.
And you see that on the weeks the human eyes were there,
the donations actually soared,
and obviously they don't need to be real human
eyes.
Week number one interestingly had sort of the highest
compliance rate
with the sort of
scary set of eyes.
Will this work in traffic? This is
sort of an interesting question.
This is from an artistic traffic calming project
in St. Paul, Minnesota, which has actually been
pretty successful, and they just renewed it.
So, one of the themes in the book
is how people sort of react to the road environment
as a piece of design, and how this has sort of been
neglected I think by
traffic engineers over the last few decades
but is becoming to be
viewed with more importance. And
instead of simply erecting more signs,
beginning to think about
other ways we can inform drivers about how to behave
in certain environments.
And when I began this
book, this was something I grew up with and
still see all over, and I thought
you know, isn't that nice, people
sort of care about our children. They're
out there sort of trying to protect them.
It turns out that these signs have been shown
to do absolutely nothing at all in terms
of speed reduction or improve the safety
children. They're sort of been banned from
the official MUTCD
because essentially they don't work. What usually
happens is that people are complaining about people
driving fast
down their street.
They call up the local engineers who
put up one of these as sort of a parental pacification
device and
walk away.
Speed management is sort of a huge issue
in America where
New York City we're about to try to get a
twenty mile an hour
speed limit campaign going. Twenty's plenty
is the idea here, but
a lot of different approaches here to managing
speed.
Interesting one here in Japan, Melody Road.
It features feedback, that if you
drive over at the proper speed, it plays a song.
If you don't drive over, it doesn't.
Here's another approach in Durham, North Carolina.
Now one reason, you know, to think about one reason
that drivers might be speeding
is that there's a variety of sort of
visual illusions that happen when we're in the car.
This is one of my favorite illusions.
It's essentially called treadmill effect. And the idea
here is to stare at the x in the center as
carefully as you can, as closely as you can
and if it works, you should see the Buddha
sort of bloom out at you. Is that working for everyone?
And you know what's going on here is
that
similar to a treadmill in a gym, when you
run on it for a while, then you stop, and the room
seems to surge backwards.
When you drive at a higher speed, at a certain speed
for a good amount of time
and then attempt to slow down,
the longer you've been driving at that higher speed,
the longer it actually takes you to slow down, for your
brain to sort of mentally catch up,
the neurons that track forward and backward motion
are getting confused.
It's sort of a long story, but
engineers, you know, are forced
to put these sort of dynamic signs that actually
remind drivers of how fast they're going as
they're entering an environment.
Another problem though is that a lot of people
are living on streets like this, and no matter
what signs
an engineer is going to put up on a street
like this,
this street is sending a variety of overt,
not-so-subtle messages that this is an environment
for cars.
I don't know why there are traffic lights on
on this first bit of street.
One of my favorite phrases, a Canadian engineer
named Ezra Hauer said
drivers adapt to the road they see,
and this road is clearly sending a very
strong
message about how to
behave. It reminds me of a
concept that Cornell University researcher,
Brian Wansink
calls portions distortion.
He's done studies that show people consume
measurably more food
when it's served to them in a larger
package,
more so than they actually even want. He's done experiments
with stale popcorn in movie theaters.
People consume more stale popcorn when they
eat it out of a larger bucket.
So I think
a lot of American roads suffer from a version of
this portion distortion. They're over-engineered
for safety.
People drive fast, and then
they're confused--
we're surprised when people consume all the extra
safety that's been built in.
This is another
image from a small town in Texas. This
is something that
has been happening around the country:
street trees,
often like this, are sort of torn out.
Is the tree a hazard, or is the
tree in fact a safety device?
I can sort of guarantee the moment you take that tree out,
speeds are going to increase, which is probably going to
pose a greater
risk to any pedestrians or cyclists
on that street. The tree is sort of an obvious
hazard, but because of various legal liability issues
we've been tearing these things out,
I think to our detriment throughout the country.
I could go on about the problems of signs,
over signage. Sometimes we don't
actually, aren't able to see them,
sometimes they sort of state
the sort of obvious,
sometimes they send... sometimes we selectively
obey signs
based on what we want to do,
and sometimes we simply don't
understand what they're trying to tell us.
I see this one in London all the time, and
every time I come across it I feel like I'm having
a mid-life crisis.
This should be on a cubicle wall or something, giving me,
you know,
positive life direction, you know.
One of my favorite studies I've looked at
had people try to--
the point here is that people often don't
understand what signs are telling them,
but one of my favorite studies had people look at
a watch for falling rocks sign.
Half the drivers said that they would look for rocks
falling in the moment and speed up,
have said they would slow down and look for rocks
already on the road, so...
I sometimes wonder if engineers really just need to
sort of spell out everything.
Now I'll conclude with perhaps one of the most absurd
warning sign cases. This involved
moose advisories in Newfoundland, Canada.
There was a foggy stretch of road that was home to not
only many car-moose collisions but
also many cars and cars stopping to take pictures of moose.
So signs...
so engineers figured so how can we combat this problem. They
erected full-size reflective silhouettes of moose,
thinking this with would help the situation.
Unfortunately, tourists found these pretty interesting, too,
and as they stopped to take pictures or the moose signs,
the moose signs themselves
became crash hot spots.
The next logical step,
and I wish this were a joke, it actually isn't,
was to create new signs that read caution moose
signs ahead.
So, just take a look at the signs you see around you
and wonder you know who's looking at them
and what are they actually doing. I think
signs I've come to think represent a failure of
imagination both symbolically and literally in
how to change behavior.
There's evidence that
context and environmental cues can be just as if
not more powerful.
Behavioral
economist Richard Thaler and Cass Sunstein have been
arguing in their book "Nudge"
that pushing people in the right direction through
what they call choice architecture can have powerful
effects, often more powerful than
actually spelling out what people are supposed
to do.
They have a favorite example of this, which is
the
urinals in the men's bathroom in Schipol Airport
in Amsterdam.
This seems strange, but apparently the
management was upset with having to do excessive
cleanups of men's careless behavior in the bathrooms of
the airport, so they painted sort of this kind of
fly device
here, and within weeks there was a measurable
improvement in the cleanliness
of the bathrooms. Men were encouraged to
aim for this, so
no science was required, a very simple, subtle
bit of
choice architecture here.
We think how does this apply to the world of traffic,
well there's been some interesting
things like Chicago's Lakeshore Drive, the curve
at Oak Street beach,
home to a crash hot spot for a number of years.
People tend to treat Lakeshore drive like kind of an
interstate highway even though
max speed is about thirty five miles an hour.
So the first response was to install more signs,
sort of warning there's this curve ahead.
Then there were some larger signs, then larger
flashing signs.
None of this was seeming to have an effect.
The final approach was to sort of paint these tranverse
parallel bars on the road that actually grow closer
to another as you get closer to the curve.
The sensation you have driving over it is that
you're driving faster than you actually are,
sort of increasing your sense of risk
without actually increasing the risk.
It creates sort of a sense of confusion, you slow down.
Accident rate has
according to the Chicago Department of Public Transportation
actually gone down thirty six percent.
They've actually added some signage, which has made it
go down even more,
but the key point is just with this
innovative paint treatment they were able to
affect a big sort of change in that.
It's not always about adding paint. Sometimes
removing paint is actually
the answer. A street...
interesting study in England looked at two roads,
trying to reduce speeds on one road.
So they took two roads, a sample road and this road,
and actually removed the center line
markings.
And we've come to assume these have
a safety purpose
to make things better for everyone, but they
found that by removing the white lines,
drivers actually drove further apart
and slower than they did on the road
with white lines, which is exactly what
they were trying to do.
So, just to conclude here about sort of
two thoughts
divided by centuries but sort of united,
Sir Isaac Newton and Henry Barnes, former traffic
commissioner of New York City, which is
there's a lot of technology and engineering in traffic
world, but
there's also a great importance on the human
factor, which is something that I've been trying to
stress in my work. And I'll
stop now, and hopefully we'll have a
I'm sure a very productive conversation. Thank you.